hello everyone this game was played in
1948 between Boris SIF and Isaac cash
Don and I couldn't really find any
information on Boris SIF as you can see
I don't even have a photo of the guy I
just put a random hoodie there it's even
a hoodie without a person but I think
coach Don was actually a very strong
American Grandmaster he won the US
Championship twice and he was the person
that won most medals playing for the
United States Olympic team he was also a
noted writer and well this game is quite
a bloodbath I mean it's a massacre but
cardan wasn't really known for his
spectacular sacrifices or anything like
that he was actually known to be quite a
positional player as they did call him
their client at capablanca or in English
the little capablanca as he had a habit
of winning end games that were seemingly
drawn something magnus carlsen
carlson is also famous for but in this
game it's like it's like I mean it's
like Rashid nage Medina played this game
with the black pieces this is this is
one amazing game so yeah let's see it
Boris if is playing white and Crashdown
is playing with the black pieces and
although I didn't find any information
on Boris if I do believe he was a strong
player as there are two games in the
database I played between Carsten and
SIF and Cardin won one game and Boris if
won the other so probably he's a very
strong player
we have d4 by Boris and Knight to f6 by
card on c4 e6 Knight to c3 and Bishop to
b4 we have the nimzo-indian defense
Queen to c2 where d5 and now a3 and here
black can capture the knight or or he
can retreat with the bishop but Chiron
plays Bishop to e7 obviously he's a
bishop man we have a see capture son d5e
capture sandy v and Bishop to b4 and
Boris is now threatening Knights to be 5
this would be very unpleasant for black
so card on defense this c6
we have h3 restricting the development
of blacks light square bishop
we have castles by cardan III rook to e8
Bishop to d3 both players simply
developing we have Knight B to d7 92 f3
and all night to f8 and this is a very
useful move as now this Knight is also
adding protection to this h7 square as
you can see the Queen and Bishop are
eyeing that pawn so now this f6 Knight
can move but also this is preparing
maybe Knight to g6 or night to e6
depending on what white place we have
Knight to e5 and now Bishop to d6 Boras
castles and now Knights the e6 attacking
that Bishop on f4 of course white wants
to preserve his bishop a bishop to H 2
and we have g6 and this does weaken the
dark squares here but this dark square
Bishop isn't really gonna be a problem
as this g6 move will come in real handy
defending on the against this Queen and
Bishop and also now this night can go to
g7 we have Knight to f3 and now Knight
to g7 and this was a very nice maneuver
Knight to d7 to f8 the e6 and out to g7
and now this night will be supporting
this Bishop when he is developed on f5
we have Bishop captures on d6 Queen
captures on d6 and now rook F 2 c1
White's plan here is what probably to go
rook c1 rook 8 the b1 and then pushed
before a 4 and B 5 so black plays of
course Bishop to 5 this was the idea of
Knight to g7 we have night to d2 maybe
where ideas of F 3 and E 4 we have rook
to e7 Cardin is preparing it to double
up on the e-file we have b4 rook a to e8
and the card on is setting up an amazing
attack here with this move rook 88 but
Boris doesn't really seem concerned or
maybe he didn't even consider this and
he plays a rook a to be 1 continuing
with his plan of a 4 and B 5 and in this
position if you if you shown if you've
shown me this position and told me that
Rashid Nativity know was playing with
the black pieces I would immediately
know what was going to happen in this
position
Isaac gosh Don played Bishop captures on
h3 and what do you play here is white
well obviously you captured a bishop if
you don't capture the bishop you're
simply a pawn down and well there's
really no good reason to do that
so we have G captures on h3 and now it's
interesting how do you continue this
attack would with the black pieces I
mean you can't really go anywhere with
the Queen all of the dark squares are
covered you can't really go Knight g4 if
you play this Knights to h5 white was
simply capture it if you play Knight h5
then there's really no good square for
the knight after that so what what was
what was Isaac's idea the idea was to
make room for the Queen and g3 and he
plays rook captures on e3 and ken white
capture this rook let's see what happens
if he does if F captures on e3 you get
Queen to g3 check came to h1 Queen to h3
check pink the g1 and now back Queen
back to g3 check Kings to h1 and our
Knight to g4 threatening checkmate on h1
h2 and you do have to stop this somehow
so nice to have one stopping this but
now Knight to f2 check and the White
King has no more squares the White Queen
has to capture the knight and white
loses the Queen and he would have some
compensation for the Queen but well with
that open King on h1 and this Knight
ready to jump into the game also the
rook is ready to capture on e3 black is
winning here so of course
Boris saw this and after rook captures
an e3 he plays the strongest move Bishop
to f1 and now the bishop will help with
the defense of the White King and now we
have Knight to f5 and again Karsten is
offering this rook on e3 and now Boris
captures it he says you don't really
have anything here he plays F captures
on e3 we have Knight a Queen to g3 check
by Karsten Fisher - G - now this Bishop
is definitely helping with the defense
and we have twin captures on e3 we have
King - h1
Knight the g3 check we have King - h2
and now Queen to f4 threatening all
sorts of discoveries we have Knight to
f3 and now rook the e2 and now well
you're attacking the Queen of course the
Queen cannot capture the rook a stroke
is defended from the night so you do
have to cap
this rook and I mean you don't have to
capture it but what you gonna play you
can play something like King to g12 you
know get away from from this nested
discovery but then again you lose the
Queen so Boris played nice captures on
e2 now attacking the Queen and here we
have Knight captures I need to with
check now there's a discovered check
from the Queen we have came to h1 and
now cache tanzanite is attacked here on
e2 from the Queen and c2 and crushed on
plays Knight to h5 and this is I mean
this is a bloodbath indeed and white
can't capture the knight now as night to
g3
would fork the king and the Queen I need
to so he plays the Queen to d2 and he
offers the exchange of Queens but we
have a knight H to g3 check we have a
king to h2 and now Knight to f1 with a
double check from the knight and the
Queen we have King to h1 and now what do
you play here is black well of course
Queen to h2 check and well only move for
white is Knight captures Queen and here
we have night F 2 G 3 checkmate and this
is one this is one amazing game black
sacrificed everything except the night
although I did say in the beginning of
the video that he was a bishop man but
obviously he's also he's also a night
man so yeah and it's I mean Alexandra
yeah I mean actually said about Isaac
card on that it will definitely be a
card and that will be a Jungian
successor as world champion after after
aliens death you know or or maybe if
someone will eventually beat him but as
coach Dan couldn't really pursue chess
he was of poor financial status he had
to support his family so he had to give
up chess and you know get a regular job
unfortunately for chess but you know
fortunately for his family so yeah this
is the game this is one amazing game I
do hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Corey Rhodes and Tony gallant for
a contribution to my channel I really
appreciate it guys thank you and yeah
that's it as usually contractive on my
previous videos here
and yeah that's it thank you for
watching and I will see you soon